okay some interesting discussions from
our reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash reddit that's our EDD
IT nearly 2,300 of our viewers and
listeners participating in the
discussion there Pat let's take a look
at some of the more interesting and
popular discussions from the red
discussion thread one that's gotten a
lot of attention will be inauguration
turn into a bloody mess and this
involves a discussion of the divisive
pneus that Donald Trump inspires people
panicking about what is going on when
when they are at a lot of these events
with loud noises etc and speculation
about whether it's going to get crazy at
the inauguration do you anticipate it
will get a little nuts I don't think
it'll be too crazy but I'm pretty sure
the protesters will outnumber the actual
Trump supporters and I think would get
kind of crazy if Trump decides to go off
script and just ad-libbed the rest of
his speech yeah because we don't believe
for a second that the script is one he
wrote but we'll deal with that a little
bit later another discussion from our
Retta discussion forum pointing out the
insanity of Betsy DeVos the incoming
education Secretary's hearing and yeah
we covered that yesterday really really
good post pointing out a lot of the
specifics about why it was arguably the
craziest confirmation hearing that that
we've seen in many many administration's
I let enjoyed seeing that analysis on
reddit another discussion the world's
eight richest people have the same
wealth as the poorest fifty percent this
actually became a bonus show story
earlier this week and we get lots of
story ideas from the reddit discussion
forum and a very very yes from we went
from 62 people holding the same wealth
as the poorest half of the world to
eight people holding the same wealth as
the poorest half of the world that may
recall consolidation of wealth and
lastly from the reddit discussion forum
someone who heard me say Pat and I say
on the bonus show that agriculture was
the first instance when there was
inequality between humans prior to that
it was hunter-gatherers who had no real
way of storing food and
really have inequality Brody pointed out
will hold on a second what about the
domestication of dogs which happened
before agriculture those who had the
domesticated dogs in a sense had more
than those who didn't interesting idea
although it didn't really cross my mind
sounds like a valid point for sure we'll
have to look into it remember you can
sign up and I've got like a frog in my
throat here remember you can sign up for
free obviously because reddit is free
unless you want to pay for a gold
membership but that's another story for
another day at david pakman.com slash
reddit re d di t join the conversation